find the area of rhombus abcd given that
the radii of the circles circumscribed
about triangles abd and acd are 12.5 and
25 respectively so let's draw ourselves
rhombus a b c d so let's draw a rhombus
so let me draw
here we go
that's a decent rhombus right over there
we know that all the sides of a rhombus
are equal and let's name let's label the
vertices so vertex a
b
c d so there we go rhombus a b c d and
then they say the radii of the circle
circumscribed about triangles abd so
triangle abd that's a b
d that is triangle abd so let's draw the
circle let's draw the it's circumcised
it's circumscribed circle or the or the
the circle that passes through the
vertices a
b and d so let me try to do my best job
at that so it would look something
something this is
not a trivial thing to do it's not
always easy
so let's
let's do it like that there we go that's
it's circumscribed circle or it's the
the circle
circumscribed about abd right over there
now they're telling us they're telling
us that its diameter is 12.5 so they're
saying that this diameter right over
here so if i were to draw a diameter of
this circle right over here it is
12.5 now the other circle the cir the
circum circle for triangle acd so let's
draw a c d a
c
a
c
d so let's draw a circle that can go
through these three points it looks like
it would have to be something
something like this
something like this it looks like it
would have to be a somewhat bigger
circle
and that that gels with the information
that they gave us
the way i drew it
so the circle would look something like
that i don't want to spend too much
trying time trying to draw that circle
but they're telling us that it's
it's
it's i should be very careful they're
saying that the radius is 12.5 not the
diameter so let me make it very clear
actually let me delete that circle since
it's just so messy
and i can delete that 12.5 too
let me get
there you go so the 12.5 is the radius
the radii of the circle so this first
circle around abd
around a triangle abd this distance
right over here is 12.5 this distance
over here is also
is also 12.5 now let's focus on triangle
acd
a c d
a
c
d
let's focus on that triangle its circum
circle
will look something like
it will look something
like this let me draw
there you oh that doesn't look too good
there you go something like that
the whole point here isn't trying to
draw a circle circle but it's a point
it's a circle that will go through those
three points
through
those three points and it has a radius
of 25 so if it you draw if you had its
center
or if i were to draw a diameter of it it
is 25 fair enough now we would need to
figure out the area of rhombus a b
c
and d
now if you've been seeing the videos
that i've been uploading lately i've
actually been uploading a few of the
prerequisites for this because there is
a formula and we prove the formula in
the geometry and the competition math
playlist we prove the formula that
relates the area of a triangle to its to
the radius of its circum circle and let
me just rewrite the formula right over
here the formula is
the radius of a triangle's circum circle
is equal to the product of the triangles
the product of the triangle's sides
all of that over four times the area
all of that over 4 times the area of the
triangle so let's see if we can use this
formula that we have proved in a
previous video to figure out areas of
triangle abd or express them somehow and
triangle acd and then see if we can use
that information to figure out the area
of the entire rhombus so let me let me
redraw it let me redraw a little bit
because i think my diagram's gotten kind
of messy
so i'll redraw the rhombus
redraw the rhombus we actually won't
even have to draw the circum circles or
the circumscribed circles because we
know this formula right over here so
this is a
b
c and d now let's think first about
triangle abd
triangle a
triangle abd actually let me just draw
the diagonals here
bd is one of the diagonals ac is another
one of the diagonals
ac is the other diagonals we know that
the diagonals of a rhombus are
perpendicular bisectors we know that
that's a right angle that's a right
angle that's a right angle that's a
right angle and we know
we know that this length is equal to
this length and we also know we also
know that that length is equal to that
length
now if we knew this green length here or
this yep blue length here we would be
able to figure out the area of the
rhombus let's label them let's call this
let's call this right over here let's
call this lowercase a
and let's call this length over here
lowercase b a times b times one-half
would be the area of this triangle right
over there
a times b times one half times two would
give us this area and that area or
another way to think about it this
triangle is completely congruent it has
sides a b and this side over here all of
these four triangles have those three
sides so all four of these triangles are
congruent so you can take the area of
of this triangle multiply it by four you
have the area of the rhombus let me
write this down the rhombus
the rhombus area
is equal to four times one half
a b one half a b gives us just
this triangle right over here four times
that which will be so four times one
half a b is two a b is going to be the
area of the rhombus if we can somehow
figure out a and b if we can figure out
a and b we can figure out the rhombus's
area so let's focus on this first piece
of information let's focus on triangle
let's focus on triangle a
triangle a b and d
now they tell us that its circum radius
is 12.5 so this let's use this formula
right over here we get 12.5
12.5 is equal to its circum radius is
12.5 is equal to the product of the
lengths of the sides so what's the
length of the sides here
so we have this side right over here
side bd that's just going to be 2a right
it's that's an a plus another a so it's
going to be 2a times
this side right over here what's this
side what's this side which is just one
of the sides of the rhombus
well that's this is a the hypotenuse of
this right triangle right over here
right this is a right angle so it's
going to be the square root of a squared
plus b squared but all of the sides are
going to be that it's a rhombus all the
sides are the same a squared plus b
squared they're all going to have that
exact same length
so the product of the sides you have 2a
that's the length of bd
times the length of ba which is going to
be the square root of a squared plus b
squared times the length of ad which is
the square root of a squared plus b
squared all of that
all of that over four times four times
the area four times the area of abd so
it's all of that over four times now
what's the area of a b and d
well abd is just two of these triangles
right over here this guy right over here
is one half a b
this guy over here is also one half a b
so the entire the entire area is going
to be two of these guys which is going
to be a times b it's going to be a times
b
it gives you the area of both of these
triangles each of them are one half a b
so instead of writing area right here i
could write i could write a b and let's
see this simplifies to this simplifies
to 12.5
is equal to divide the numerator and the
denominator by two so that becomes a one
that becomes a two divide by a that
becomes a one that becomes a one square
root of a squared plus b squared times
square root of a squared plus b squared
is just a squared plus b squared
a squared plus b squared and in the
denominator we're just left with a two b
two b so this first piece of information
the circum radius for abd being 12.5
gives us this equation gives us this
equation right over here now let's do
the same thing for triangle acd
triangle a a c
a c d its circum radius is 25
25 is equal to
is equal to the length of this side this
is a b this is also a b so it's going to
be 2b
2b times the length of this side which
is just the square root of a squared
plus b squared times the length of this
side which is again just the square root
square root of
a squared plus b squared all of that
over
four times the area now the area once
again it's this triangle
which is one half a b plus this triangle
which is another one half a b you add
them together you just get a b
you just get a b
two and divide by two you get a one
there you get a two here divide by b get
a one that just becomes an a and so you
get 25
is equal to the numerator square root of
a squared b b squared times itself is
just going to be a squared plus b
squared over
over 2
over 2a so that second triangle at
circum radius being 25 gives us this
equation right over here now we can use
both of these we have two equations with
two unknowns let's solve for a and b if
we know a and b we can then go back here
and figure out the rhombus's area
so over here we get
over here we get let's multiply both
sides by 2b
we get
25
b is equal to a squared plus b squared
over here if we multiply both sides by
2a
we get 50
a is equal to a squared plus b squared
so 50a is equal to a squared plus b
squared 25b is equal to a squared plus b
squared so 25b must be the same thing as
50a they're both a squared plus b
squared so we get 25 b
must be equal to
must be equal to 50 a they're both equal
to a squared plus b squared now divide
both sides by 25 you get
you get b is equal to
b is equal to 2a
b is equal to actually i want to do that
in the magenta
b is equal to
b is equal to 2a so we can take this
information and then now substitute back
into either one of these equations to
solve for to solve for b and then we
could solve for a so let's go back into
this one so we get
we get 50a
actually we'll solve for a first 50 a is
equal to a squared plus b squared
instead of writing b squared we know b
is the same thing as 2a so let's write
2a squared
2a squared so we get 50
50a
is equal to a squared plus
a squared plus 4a squared or we get 50a
is equal to 5a squared divide both sides
we could divide both sides by 5 a
if we divide this side by 5a we get 10
and if we divide this side by 5a we get
a so a is equal to 10 and then we could
just substitute back here to figure out
b 2 times a is equal to b b
is equal to 2 times 10 which is equal to
20. so we know a is 10 b is 20. we just
have to go right back here to figure out
the area of the rhombus the area of the
rhombus is equal to two times
a was ten
two times ten times twenty this is
twenty times twenty this is equal to
this is equal to
400 and we're done the area of rhombus
abcd is 400.